مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزره من قناه
الجزيره قال رئيس الاوكراني ميرزا نيسكي
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تقاتل من اجل تحقيق
النصر في مواجهه الغزو الروسي وفي لقاء مع
السفراء اوكرانيا في الخارج عقب عودته من
واشنطن حيث حصل على تعهدات بدعم النوعيه
كشفاز المسك ان بلاده تعد لايشائي وكاله
ستوسع جغرافيه النفوذ الاوكرانيه على احد
وصفها
قال السفير الروسي في الولايات المتحده
ان مخاطر الصدام بين روسيا والولايات
المتحده مرتفعه واكد ان تنوبسكو
ستكون اهدافا مشروعه اضطرابات في اوكرانيا
نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه متحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه دعوه بلاده الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الى الاعتراف
بالواقع وصحب جيشه من اوكرانيا بعد وصفه
اخيرا النزاع هناك بانه حرب اضاف انه مهما
كانت مصطلحات هبوط فانه عدوان روسي على
جارتها ذات السياده لم يخلف سوى الموت
والدمار والنزوح على حد تعبير المسؤول
الامريكي
قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
قد تقلص انتاجها من النفط بما يتراوح بين
خمسه وسبعه في المئه في اوائل العامل مقبل
ردا على اجراءات الغرب وضع سقفين اسعار
النفطي والمنتجات البتروليه الروسيه
وبينما سجلت الاسواق وارتفاعها في اسعار
النفط نقلت وكاله
ايضا لحضره تصدير النفط والمنتجات
البتروليه الى الدول والكائنات القانونيه
التي ستطلب الامتثاله للسقف الاسعار في
العقود
عضلات النيابه العامه الفرنسيه مقتله
ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه اخرين في اطلاق نار
وسط باريس ونقلت رويترز عن محامي ان
القتلى الثلاثه من افراد الجاليه الكرديه
المحليه وقال مراسل الجزيره من الشرطه
اعتقلت مطلق النار وهو رجل الستيني وفتحت
تحقيقا في الحادثه وحولت التحقيق لشرطه
مكافحه الجرائم وذكرت وسائل الاعلام
الفرنسيه الى مطلق النار سبق ان هاجم
مخيما للاجئين في فرنسا العام الماضي وعدن
المدعي العام الفرنسي انه يحقق في وجودي
دوافع عنصريه الهجوم
وقد اندلعت مواجهه بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
وافراد من الجاريه الكرديه في العاصمه
باريس احتجاجا على مقتل ثلاثه افراد في
حادث اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]